you think dog the bounty hunter is going
to get brian laundry yeah he has to it's
the only way back dude yeah wait what do
you mean
dude he said the n-word yeah okay right
unforgivable
forgive him
he said the n-word which is unforgivable
right um
from black people black people do not
forgive white people and it's you know
we we're a little bit more forgiving
i just googled the story and according
to the headline dog the bounty owner
says he thought he had a pass to use the
n-word oh you got to see it like eminem
no no it's amazing who also didn't have
a piano
like he uh muted it out of every uh
album no he said it in like rap battles
and [ __ ] he said it back in the day like
when he was with his boys and [ __ ] like
that but but with dog it's super funny
because uh the interviewer who's black
asks him he goes well why who gave you
this pass and he goes
the brothers
which i mean who else is gonna give it
to you
i would hope
but uh but yeah if he gets brian laundry
i mean you got to re-up the show
is there forgiveness
ow is there forgiveness if he finds the
killer of a white queen do black men
forgive him we still don't know if he's
a killer what if she was alive and maybe
you could have sex with her we still
don't know if he's the killer he took
her van bro it's innocent until proven
guilty bro
[Laughter]
yo he's not wrong
it's innocent to prove guilty even if he
did kill her he's still innocent what
about o.j did he kill her no
[Laughter]
that's true
anthony yeah
now it's the same logic though he was
proven innocent now let me ask you
what's proven guilty so he's innocent oh
so he's definitely innocent he
definitely didn't yeah what about casey
anthony i don't know enough about that
one
she was proven innocent casey anthony's
dead she wasn't proven guilty so then
she's wait what happened to casey yeah i
don't know i don't know i truly don't
know anything about this woman people
are suggesting that she killed her
daughter because her daughter was
missing and found the woods some kids be
annoying
and then they tried her for first degree
murder you got too many people and then
she was like
she was found not guilty
say what she was found guilty
[Applause]
deal with the girl and what she needs
she's tired yeah she loves nutella at
two in the morning you're like alright
get this thing out of here bro i can't
be getting you nutella at two in the
[ __ ] morning
yeah why this kid got a sweet tooth he
ain't even got teeth yet
what's up with this kid's dying
yeah man
all right so we got dwayne chapman going
out for a dog or going out for brian
laundry
my question is what dwayne chapman that
that's dog bounty okay come on come on
don't use his government
don't use this i use people's government
names
hey tell me you didn't think that was a
black dude though dwayne
yeah exactly
and on top of that y'all know white
dwayne dwayne reed never
the wealthiest black man in new york
dwayne reed
but go on and on top of that he even
said that i have never been racist i'm
33 and a half percent apache
and uh and he i thought i had a lot of
percent yeah yeah so he's native
american this whole time no native
americans don't get the past americans i
thought i had a pass in the black tribe
to use it tried he called him a try yeah
which i feel like it's kind of more
racism than a woman guys treating them
like they're from africa
yeah i like that i thought that's what
the reservation's for they're waiting
for their n-word passes
[Laughter]
we are the foremost journalists of
flagrance so absolutely in the world
that's the fact
you could trace it back okay but no
right his quotes on this [ __ ] yeah what
do you say i i just got out of prison in
1979 after spending 18 months in texas
and it was probably three quarters of
the black tribe in the jail so that was
so that was the word that we use back
and forth as maybe a compliment my pass
expired for using it dot dot dot but no
one told me that to say a racist name
doesn't qualify you to make you a racist
so he said bro he says his past expired
but he didn't realize it was just out of
date he just made him re-up it's his
tags like his tags were up and then no
one was like yo your tags are up
that's all i've seen though i kind of
respect it once i know he's a native
american he kind of gets about 30 that's
not nothing how do you become 33 though
threesome
like must be he must be a three plus b
yeah i mean no disrespect to dog mom but
like
she was getting crazy from right like
33 like that's such a specific person
how are you a third because if it's half
and half then you're a quarter if it's
half and full
yeah that's what i'm saying it don't
make sense that's why i said threesome
i've been to thrizzy yeah um might have
hit the threezy one time with an apache
and two whites yo
that's thanksgiving right yeah foursome
wait why apache and two whites
the dudes getting up in it yeah you're
not the journalist of math today
oh so who's the apache oh but apaches
are two spirit actually so it might be a
foursome yeah there you
go agree with you that's good this is
true no but the mom dukes is white girl
right i'm assuming yeah and then one
apache one white
yeah so i guess that means his dad was
66 apache somehow
so i don't really know how the math
breaks down
no
full apache white mom white dad
and the apache dude up in there
guts yeah two sperm interlocks made a
teepee
so i think that's it and the fact that
he's native american might make it
easier for him to find brian laundry
why because he knows the label he can
track yeah racist how's that brian
laundry got footprints he's not racist
saying the native americans know the lay
of the land right right right yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it'd be
racist they know the land of the lakes
yeah yeah that's what i meant to say i
was actually traveling
i was like i actually said progressively
what he wanted to say that's what i was
calling it yeah you wanted to be racist
yeah and i knew where you were going you
don't have a pass bro yeah
no could you say that
[Applause]